standing on the scale the wheel is
spinning and still weighs 91 kilograms
you made you prediction let's see what
happens when I throw it up over my head
in three two one
what do you think I don't know about you
but to me it looked like a shaky mess
let's watch that again in slow-mo and I
will graph the scale readings as you can
see during the lift the scale oscillates
around 91 kilograms the same as it read
when I was stationary so it seems the
apparatus doesn't get heavier or lighter
when it is lifted while spinning the
only large deviation from the average
comes at the end of the lift when I let
the wheel fall so the scale reading
drops and then I slow its descent and so
the scale reading Rises so the question
remains if the wheel doesn't get lighter
why does it feel lighter this
demonstration was first performed by
Professor Eric lathe wait listen to how
he describes it so here goes 40 pounds
of wheel as light as a feather this is
not a conjuring trick this is a fact of
science he sure makes it look easy
doesn't he watch it again carefully a
fact about a spinning wheel so far
everyone has missed professor lathe
weight claimed the gyroscopes properties
couldn't be fully explained by Newton's
laws of motion I disagree but in order
to understand why the wheel feels so
light we first have to consider why it
feels heavy when it's not spinning so
two-handed that's as far down the shaft
as you can hold it yep holding the shaft
horizontally you clearly need to provide
an upward force equal to the downward
weight of the wheel but this is not
enough because with only these two
forces there would be a net torque
causing the apparatus to rotate so you
need to create a counter torque in
addition to supporting the weight of the
wheel this requires pushing down with
one hand and pulling up with the other
and the upward force must be greater
than the downward force by an amount
equal to the weight of the wheel so the
force on each of your hands is
significantly greater than the weight of
the wheel now once the wheel is spinning
the torque due to its way
now causes it to process rather than
fall to the ground therefore no counter
torque is necessary you only need to
supply an upward force equal to the
wheels weight so it feels lighter now
the trick to lifting a wheel over your
head is to push it forwards as you
release it lathe weight new this if you
force a gyroscope to process faster it
lifts up how a the possession and
averages but the weight doesn't change
similarly if you slow the precession of
a gyroscope it goes down by the
precession and their Falls dramatically
are you sure do you ride
it's hard to go back the way that it
doesn't want to process their kansai it
becomes as light as a feather and it's
Raj it certainly doesn't become as light
as a feather I can say that that too
from having felt it but it does feel
lighter and I think maybe part of that
has to do with the fact that I'm not
having to counter the torque with my
hand you know all I have to do is
support the weight of the disc but I
don't need to provide any torque with my
hand to counter that gravitational
torque which is what makes it feel so
awkward when you're trying to hold it
when it's static when you apply a torque
as you were that there's a force up on
one side of the head and down on the
other side and if you would decrease the
force on both side then it will actually
feel lighter it feels like it without
actually getting like yeah yeah what it
does is to decrease the apparent weight
that you're feeling we wash
you